Hi, welcome to the WebGL
debugging screencast. In this
screencast, I'm going to go
through the basics of
debugging your WebGL
applications.
To get started, I have here the
Khronos WebGL wiki page
about debugging.
This is a nice source
of links.
It links you to WebGL Inspector,
which is nice for
WebGL debugging.
It also has a link to the WebGL
debug scripts, which is
a little piece of JavaScript
that gives you tools to debug
your WebGL applications.
In particular, it has got a
WebGL debug context, which is
a special wrapper for a WebGL
context that makes all GL
errors show up in the
JavaScript console.
So you can also customize
it to do
JavaScript style error handling.
So that instead of getting back
an error number, you can
make it actually throw an
exception when you get an
error on a GL call.
And what the debug context does
is after each call to GL,
it calls gl.geterror to
get the error code.
This causes a performance
penalty if you use it in your
production code.
But for debugging, it's great.
It also has this little
function,
WebGLDebugUtils.glEnumToString,
which lets you take one of
those cryptic error codes and
gets the name for the error.
Very useful.
Next, I'm going to show you
the WebGL Inspector.
So the WebGL Inspector
is a little Chrome
extension by Ben Vanik.
And it's probably easier to
show you what it does.
So it is on GetHub,
benvanik.gethub.
com/WebGL-Inspector.
I'm going to show you the live
demo of the WebGL Inspector.
So here we have a WebGL demo
running on the screen.
And click on the UI button, we
get the WebGL Inspector.
And now I'm going to go through
some of the easy features.
So Programs tab, you have got
the shaders and the GL
programs. And these have the
uniforms, the attributes, the
shader sources, the status
for the shaders.
So if you've got problems
with your shaders,
you can see it here.
Then there's a Buffers pane,
which shows you all the
buffers used in your
WebGL program.
And here you can see what is
inside of buffer, what is the
size of the buffer, and
what has been done
to the buffer recently.
If we look up--
I think it's this one.
Yeah, here we have
an 89k buffer.
And here is a 600k buffer.
And with these, you don't see
the buffer contents directly.
But you have to click on this
link to show them, which I'm
not going to click, because I
think it's going to crash the
browser if I do that.
I'll do that anyway.
Let's see what happens.
Yeah.
OK, well, that was surprisingly
fast. So 89k
buffer, perfectly OK.
No problem.
You also have a Textures pane
that shows you all the
textures in your WebGL
application, texture settings
and what has been done
to the texture.
And in the Textures pane, you
can see all the textures in
your WebGL program.
And you can see the texture
parameters for each texture
and the texture content.
Because this is a texture that
was passed as a null texture--
that is it is a GPU site texture
that the WebGL program
is editing in the GPU--
we don't see anything in
the texture contents.
This is one problem with WebGL
Inspector at the moment which
I think could be fixed.
But if you have a normal
texture, you should see the
contents of the texture A-OK.
In the State panel, you get a
state snapshot of the current
WebGL context state.
It has all the blending and
the blend colors, color
values, maximum attributes
and such like.
In the Timeline pane, you can
see what's happening in your
WebGL program.
The timeline view shows you what
you are doing with WebGL.
So it shows you how much time
it takes per frame to render
your WebGL scene.
And it shows you how many
textures you are allocating,
how many programs you are
using, and so on.
Now If we go the Trace panel--
this is the first panel, but
I'm taking the class.
So the Trace panel is the last
panel that I'm going to go to.
And when I click on the Capture
button, what I get
here is what happened
during this frame.
Here's the image that was drawn,
and then all the DL
calls we did to draw
that frame.
Very useful, very nice.
Let's move on.
So for Unit Testing GL, the Maps
GL team here at Google
built this little thing,
glsl-unit, which is a unit
testing framework for GLSL
code in the WebGL.
And--
testing frameworks that allows
you to write and run Unit
Tests for your WebGL
GLSL code.
GLSL units will run your test
code on the graphics card and
extract the results.
So it will be identical to the
execution environment of your
shader coding production.
And that is the great thing
about GLSL units.
If you want to hear more about
GLSL units and how the Maps
team was developing WebGL, you
can go to this YouTube talk
from GTAC 2011.
It's Developing and
Testing WebGL.
It's by Roy Williams, one
of the MapsGL engineers.
And GTAC stands for Google Test
Automation Conference.
And this is a great talk for
real-life WebGL use in a
non-game setting.
So go there and check it out.
This is about all I have
to say about WebGL
debugging for now.
So thanks for watching
and get hacking.